hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play Vapor now I
got about a thousand emails from you
guys and messages all over the place
saying that I needed to play this
because it was one of the scariest games
ever in the history of forever and then
I saw the yummy bass played is who I
asked him if it really was one of the
scariest games ever and I'm oh I'm
actually in the game right now bobbing
up and down like a cork in the ocean why
am I just swimming here no I'm actually
floating am i a ghost is that why this
is a scariest game ever so anyway so I
decided that I had to play it I haven't
seen any gameplay of it so obviously I'm
going into this blind to see if this
really is one of the scarier games I
gotta say first right off the bat the
ambience is very good and um this is
made on the Unity engine of course um
which is a very flexible engine and I'm
really proud to say that these aren't
the static trees that you've seen in all
the other ones it's actually some effort
put in to put some foliage on the ground
and get some good atmosphere and
ambience and hello hi cricket how are
you doing even wait I just saw where'd
it go I just saw something oh there it
is okay
I'm going towards the light is this how
I die am ia ghost floating and bouncing
in there can I run okay I can run good I
can run really fast okay well well
that's disconcerting it's a double ring
of skulls around a fire I see a green
light over there what does it say
combust combust combust what what am i
combusting here I have no idea okay
let's just follow the lights until we
find something worth value with Sprint
please yes thank you alright
so nice fog I mean it's really dense
kind of creepy don't know about scary
just yet but let's find out later hello
a grand light where are you oh there you
are okay yeah who's that
Oh what are you you're like headcrabs
what the hell oh hi oh you're a hand
oh that's grody get away from me stop
grabbing at me I'm not that kind of
woman I'm not any kind of woman but
don't grab at me oh okay I got something
then there's another light over there
are you am I just supposed to be
collecting the lights good get away from
me okay so you're some weird hand
creature
oh you're oh you're a dead body
underground describe to reaching out
your grave okay I get it I get it
okay so whoa what was that I saw it up
to get the fog what was that
okay I can't move what can I move what's
going on
what happened something happened what
happened hello
well aren't you whoa what is that what
is that ah it's a hand but it's all
different wait he went away it was a
hand but it's all burnt what was that I
got away from me yeah you're so weird
okay anyway so there's a red thingy here
and now my heart's thumping where are
those things okay what it wait there's
somewhere to collect collect what did I
grab that hand out of the ground wait no
this fire went out why this fire go out
what is going on I am so confused
this is so weird what was that thing I
saw in the shadows
and why is there blood everywhere so
weird here's another red thing huh oh
wait no I can't get you oh come on baby
don't be like that I love the way your
three legs swirl around come on let me
okay
maybe I don't know I don't know why I
can't get that this tree is a little
black and compared to the others I've no
idea what I'm supposed to do here but
wait oh my god get away from me where
you going on there doing it
Jesus Christ what was that what did i do
what did i do holy crap what the hell
was that I'm sorry for whatever I did I
am so sorry
hahaha okay alright then so that God job
started into horrifying I don't know
what was going on there
I stopped him that wasn't what I saw in
the shadows anyway that was some
different Oh some horrible I think it
got me but I couldn't tell what was
going on because it kept flashing me
back to the pile of bones look maybe I'm
supposed to take it to the pile but it
was following me but I couldn't I
couldn't go anywhere oh man alright then
so anyway excuse me let me just collect
it there was also something oh okay
that's what I thought when I was
spastically clicking and spamming and I
could fire like these green balls so I'm
assuming that's what that was from it
die you [ __ ] can I kill you did I kill
you yeah right away back into your hole
okay so this said collect and there was
this red thing I'm wondering if that had
something to do with it okay anyone want
to die oh wait does that hurt is it good
was that knotted there was something
there's that hand sticking out of the
ground oh oh again know to back off I
got green balls of goo just at firing
out of my ass so what is with this this
is so weird and then there's this thing
oh I collect that okay
so I have this I'm gonna go back to the
fire circle before
uh what are you your that thing I saw oh
you're just a scholar fine okay he
exploded that's nice
oh so I can kill these things ah you
know I got me
okay those so die hi hi bumpy ha ha that
they add good
die you [ __ ] hello guru where's Ethel
where's the fire where's the fire
where's the fire
give me to the wire give me to the fire
burn burn in the fire you I don't care
about you guys I care about that other
thing
aah aah I don't wanna date you burn you
burn your [ __ ] weren't you burning your
jeez go red right out god I got a
goddamn good run run run run run run run
run run run run run okay good god man
get away from me
I gotta get back to that bag get off and
oh my god hang on gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme
yes right there dig you go on No
hmm
what am I doing wrong I'm trying I'm
trying my best
I really am why are you doing this to me
holy crap that is so freaky I can't even
begin to scribe how freaky that is you
guys gotta play this game it's oh it's
amazing okay so I don't know what I'm
supposed to do here it's so weird I
thought I thought if I couldn't cry kept
getting caught because it kept jerking
me away and put like throwing images at
me oh man that thing is weird oh my god
that's so weird and so cool
there's so cool okay so as I'm running
those hands come out of the ground and
they grab on him I'm pretty sure they're
I see you yeah you you think are you you
think I don't care about you I grab I
love you ill yeah stop thrust is a skull
and a pelvis and your thrusting it at me
okay so as I collected that thing this
fire went out so I'm thinking that I
gotta find other things like that like
the hand reaching out of the ground and
I just got a hurry before that thing
gets me which it's gonna get me I know
it is so before the I hear you know okay
I get away for a la is so weird
get off my god let go let go let me go
you son the [ __ ] it you better like
dump Frick frack go from me okay what is
this thing I don't know what the red
thing does maybe it's like a protective
ward to keep him away from me guy
doesn't know no no no no no no get off
of me you get off of me get oh I'm just
gonna bunnyhop until I go into the other
side of the frickin world here to get
away from that son of a [ __ ] you mother
humpers I will kill you I will kill you
and you will die and then I will kill
you and that you will die I'll cop into
Dylan got the mountain go with the baton
no no no no up the mountain you can't
follow me off the mountain oh oh that's
not good
why is it keep focusing on that thing
it's the two points it keeps doing it
and it's just doing its word uh-uh
yeah get away from me you son of a [ __ ]
you're ugly you're fat no one likes you
I I punch you in the face get away get
away stop doing that okay I think I'm
getting farther away from it I hope I
really hope okay all right let's just
take a breather here that thing is a son
of a [ __ ] I still hear it in the
background thank you very much so what
do I do
I don't burn it says combust but I don't
know what I'm supposed to combust I
don't see any more guiding lights oh man
okay anyway whoa what is this hello okay
there's green things as red things what
do they do
wait oh wait no I got rapid fire okay so
that's a thing
so I'm collecting power-ups but these
don't seem to help me with anything
I've known it'll seem to help it when it
comes to that horrifying thing whatever
is following me oh I hear it I hear it I
hear it I hear it I hear I did get away
from a I know what I do every night
okay show you we're my rapid fire go I'm
just gonna keep shooting green balls of
goo in your face and hopefully that will
deter you from following me oh man
you're so weird what am I supposed to do
I've Noah wait a minute that light that
wasn't there before the light went out
before what is this ah screw you yeah I
don't care about you guys you just slow
me down that's all you guys do bursts
into a million pieces
I wish I had my rapid fire there we go
kaboom Kabang II and shut up where'd the
light go the light was there I saw the
light where'd it go where'd it go
where'd it go I saw the frigging now oh
yeah bye
I saw the light my god get away for me I
saw the light where'd the light go
I saw get off of me you sand bat there
it is I'm just gonna keep following in
this direction just keep going just keep
swimming just keep swimming don't get
Ryback all right why did that disappear
it disappears whether you like I'd find
a tree or a rock or something okay what
are you what are you
aha
okay combine what does combined mean
there's something here okay I got a
thing I just need to did I get it did I
get it okay I'm going back uh no I'm not
I'm going back to home base eventually
but I get these [ __ ] skulls on my ass
okay hopefully I'll be able to see
another light from the top of that point
oh that son of a [ __ ] you stay away
from me and you die in a pit of fire you
son of a [ __ ] okay all right okay all
right okay
Oh what did I do yeah I did something
what did I do
oh yeah yeah another light and whatever
this red thing is I don't know but I got
okay alright wait in this back where the
first one was no this is different okay
this is different okay yeah I got it
okay I get it yeah I'm looking at you
don't need to show to me I'm already uh
get away from me no wait for me whoa
what are you Oh what are you wow wow wow
wow whoa what the hell I am moving I am
[ __ ] it burn it
no there's another thing over there I
gotta go get it what the hell this
happened I don't even know it was so
quick someone go back and replay that
what the hell what the hell what the
hell what the half what the half
I gotta make oh don't let me look at it
whoa what is that oh god oh my god that
is weird
what did i do I got something give me
the rapid fire I can barely move what's
going on here give me the rapid fire oh
my god no no no no no no you stay the
frig crack back yeah that's right ah no
no I got a guy no get away get away get
away get away get away I'm too loose oh
my god oh my god oh my god
get away get away get away get away get
away get away I got I got the thing I
got that thing the other thing don't do
it
yeah I get it maybe did I do it I did
something oh another one
hoo-wee crap I did I am I
no I'm done okay what's our it I gotta
go up that mountain I like it up that
mountain
my vision is gone Oh wha what just
happened something happened oh what the
hell is going on I was faster I slowed
down I picked up the red thing and I
slowed down how do I get up there I
don't know how I get up there we could
try to bunny up but I don't know hang on
there's got to be a way to do I hear
that thing he's got to be away
ah I'm exploiting my way up I did this
in World of Warcraft all the time I
cleanse straight up the mountain this is
our this is how we do come on come on
it's like in Skyrim to just lead your
horse right up the edge ah I'm so close
oh this is totally not the right way to
do this but I don't care I'm getting
there I'm gonna get it I'm gonna get it
I'm gonna get it ah I love that
get good gimme gimme oh so close ah come
on no no no come on come on
I'm right there oh damn it okay alright
wait I see this series of rocks and
that's all I need
that's all I needed okay alright okay
the blue which wasn't that super speed
apparently not okay
I get off of me Java mate hang on I'm
gonna get this
oh not oh that is that is whoa my my
stuff turned blue why did it turn blue
Oh what oh ok I'm out I'm out I'm out
guys I'm out I'm out get away from me no
no don't like on me look at me look at
my oh my god
let go of me you're weird you really win
let go of me
you suck imagine like happy no no no no
not now not now not now oh you
[ __ ]
why get off of me Oh No
Oh No it froze my vision to look at
something why that is so stupid ah I hit
my mic ah I was right there I was gonna
get it oh my god that was amazing but I
mean although so stupid why did that
happen those [ __ ] oh man I feel like
I was really close to the end there [ __ ]
I'll just have to pick this up later I'm
all out of time for now but man this was
incredible this is a really good game
it's so different from everything else
we've experienced at whor it's different
and that's amazing and it's a good
difference this is this is an amazing
horror game and I'm spit all over my mic
but man you guys gotta play this game it
is absolutely incredible you guys were
right suggesting this to me this was
absolutely wonderful it was an amazing
war game and I'll try to finish it I
feel like I was right there close to the
end and I have a feeling that thing's
gonna come after me if I'm standing here
but anyway so anyway thank you guys so
much for suggesting it thank you guys so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done if you
got some tips for me to do like to beat
it was I doing something wrong cuz I was
just flailing following the lights
that's pretty much all I was doing the
entire time so if you guys got a
suggestion let me know in the comments
below thank you all so much for watching
and as
I will see you in the next video bye
Oh
you
but it woman
Oh
yeah